so hello everybody i am here with tom
holland
tom holland is a novelist and author
historical author
he has written several books and his
latest book called dominion
looks at the intellectual impact and
moral impact of christianity on the west
and how it shaped
the way the west saw itself and how it
uh saw morality and its own identity
i i finished reading the book a few
weeks ago and i was very impressed
several people
kept pointing me towards the book and
said you have to read dominion you have
to read dominion because it fell
within this strange post secular
or i would say people who are
questioning the way that secular society
has viewed itself in the past few
few years and so it felt like his book
fell right into there and so
i'm really excited to have this
discussion with him and to explore a
little bit about his idea of what this
means for
for the world today and so uh so tom
thank you for accepting to do this i
thought maybe i could start maybe you
can tell me a little bit just to start
for people who don't know about you what
the impetus for writing
this book particular book was um
well thanks very much for having me um
the i guess this is a book that had been
kind of
brewing in my mind for maybe a couple of
decades really
um i about so in end of
right at the end of um the 1990s
um i began writing a history aimed at a
popular
market set in in the period that i'm
particularly interested in which is
the classical roman in particular
um so i wrote i wrote a book about the
fall of the roman republic
and then i wrote a book about um the the
greco-persian wars so
uh marathon from what police alamus and
so on
and this had always these had always
been the kind of periods that i'd loved
as a
child and i'd kind of identified with
the greeks i'd identified with the
romans
i'm in the greek context i'd always like
really identified with their gods
but the process of writing these books
and having to really get inside the
heads
of of these very alien people brought
home to me
just how far removed i was as someone
living in the late 20th century early
21st century
from pretty much everything they took
for granted and in
in the introduction you kind of
mentioned the moral side the ethical
side
but i think in a sense it kind of went
even deeper than that it was pretty much
every aspect of classical society
seemed increasingly weird and i
i guess things that seem might seem
familiar
they they they were kind of false
friends they kind of deluded you into
thinking that
you know just because the romans um had
dinner parties
or uh enjoyed public entertainments or
kind of worried about their property
somehow they were like us actually they
weren't at all and
lots of things that i kind of lazily
assumed were pretty fundamental
um sex family how you view society i
came to realize weren't unique
these were not at all how
people in the cr pre-christian world had
understood things
um and it was as fundamental as as the
problems that i had
writing about them that using it the
english language i began to realize
that there were so many words that were
just freighted with all kinds of
significations all kinds of meanings
that would have meant nothing to the
romans nothing to the greeks
and the more i thought about it the more
i came to realize
that what was stopping me
from feeling a sense of commonality with
the romans
was basically christianity that
christianity
was like a kind of great cloud of
incense
that had gusted up and although i could
see through the incense clouds i could
kind of make out
the shape of of roman history it was
almost impossible to get rid of this
this incense cloud and in a way it kind
of
distorted what what what i was seeing
and so
that was something that i felt uh you
know writing um
about the classical world over two
decades now and then also
i wrote a book about the origins of
islam so i i had to kind of really
immerse myself in the islamic world in
the way that
that islam has has kind of calibrated
how it understands reality and and again
that served to sharpen for me just
how deeply christian my assumptions
were and so i wrote dominion basically
to put that thesis to the test see
how you know
how how far back can i trace what i take
for granted
as a westerner in the early 21st century
how far back do they go and where and
what if i trace these leads back
where do they end up and almost
invariably it ended up
i i thought with christianity and and so
that's i wrote the book
i'm not 100 certain that that this
thesis would would
um would turn out to be okay but i'm
hugely relieved
that actually uh pretty much he did i
mean the process of writing it
confirmed me in my kind of gut what had
been a gut instinct
it seems to me i mean this is something
that i've also been thinking about for
for decades as well the i would call it
the enlightenment overlay of the
classical world or
kind of like the the influence of edward
gibbon especially on the way we
understand
christianity and the way we understand
the ancient world
we and the renaissance as well these
kind of
moments in in christian history or these
moments in western history where people
have tried to revive
the classics they've always done it in a
way that
ended up putting a christian veneer on
those classics and ended up putting a
christian veneer on there
even though they used ancient society or
this notion of the
of the greek city or the roman empire
as a way to criticize the contemporary
world they nonetheless were doing it
through christian eyes and they couldn't
help it
and and it seems like today with
post-modernism
one of the great effects of
post-modernism is that because it's
breaking down grand narratives it's
actually
helping us see more clearly those things
like
we have a capacity to look let's say at
the classical world for
look at it for what it is rather than be
blind at our own presuppositions as much
as we did let's say
50 or 60 years ago yeah i i think it's
i mean in almost in all kinds of ways
when when we look back at the classical
world we're looking at it through
christian lenses um
and that's kind of obvious you know if
you're talking about aristotle
or um the idea of what let's say
democracy
would be would be an example that i'm
thinking about a great deal at the
moment oddly
because i'm writing a children's book
i'm writing a book for young adults
which is a history of ancient greece
and the gimmick in this is that um the
gods are real
so they actually exist and the legends
that the athenians tell about themselves
are true
so the athenians thought that they were
sprung from the soil they were
autonomous
um they believed that um
they had to uh pay respect to the gods
or else
you know the city would fall to pieces
they felt that they had a particular
relationship with goddess athena
obviously and in a sense there was this
kind of
matrix of um they're born from the soil
the gods look after them so you've got
earth and you've got heaven
and democracy is an attempt to give
um form to that and um
it we translate it as people power but
actually demos doesn't really mean
people in that sense
demos is the kind of totality of people
who live within attica
who who have been shaped by this kind of
autonomous origin
and who are the favorites of athena and
so in that sense it includes women
as well as men the role of men is to
fight
and to debate in the assembly but the
role of women is to tend the temples
to and in particular to kind of relate
to
say demeter at the great shrine of
elusive
uh and particularly to mediate with
athena and
if you look at democracy through
contemporary eyes
secular eyes then that idea seems
ridiculous because
because we think of um something called
religion which is separate to
the important things that the men are
doing so what what the women are doing
is kind of mad stuff
that you shove in a corner maybe give a
couple of paragraphs in a book
but otherwise don't think about but if
you kind of it's about rewilding ancient
greece if you bring the gods back
then suddenly this seems incredibly
important and you understand that
the way that we understand democracy as
being about rights
as being about um rights that that
individuals have
that this is holy alien to the way the
greeks understood it
but we that we think of democracy in
that terms because we've been
christianized because we
our understanding of democracy is about
you know essentially the idea that every
voter in a state
has value by virtue of um
well of what i mean kind of essentially
ideas of rights
um the greeks had no sense of rights at
all that wasn't what they were about
and so we s our what we mean by
democracy and what the athenians meant
by democracy
is completely different and we cannot
really even imagine what it's like to
live in a state
where athena is real because
those gods have been banished so
completely by christianity
that in that sense we are their heirs
complete
we're we're we're soviets of
christianity that we don't even realize
what it is that we're seeing when we
look back at the pre-christian world of
democracy
yes but there are new gods on the
horizon right now it seems
as we look around we can see as
christianity is waning
and i think that we like you said we
can't avoid the
christian overlay but within that waning
we can see these
these new gods kind of pop up and they
they have a christian veneer to them
you know like the social justice god has
a has a strange christian taste to it
but there's something else going on
which is
i'm not sure exactly what what it is
there's also something in your
in your text which i really appreciate
it i think that the the chapters that i
appreciated the most
were the the modern chapters or the mod
the when they start
when we start at the enlightenment
because we have in the enlightenment
narrative is such an important part of
the way that we're trained in school
because the the training of our mind
also has a there's a reason why they
train them the way they do
and as you talk about the enlightenment
and then at the end of the enlightenment
you talk about the vande massacre
and then you bring in assad the marquis
de sade at the end
there's this this idea that as christian
as the christian veneer starts to fade
there's also something else
there's a promise to something else on
the horizon which is coming
uh and is and and is not necessarily
what you what you might expect
well the marquis de sade is is um
is a kind of um the great
satirist of the enlightenment and of the
pretensions of the french revolution
um because sard
kind of properly recognizes what it is
to reject christianity
and his contempt for christianity
foreshadows nietzsche's which is
kind of similarly blistering that
um both sard and nietzsche are able to
identify in the classical world the kind
of will to power
the the contempt for the weak uh the
the the kind of adoration of the strong
there was a kind of very
you know a vital part of of the way that
um classical culture did kind of
understand the world
and which we tend to shrink from um
and part of what the enlightenment
was doing was was kind of riffing on on
a kind of
a christian idea that um
idol and idols have to be toppled and
superstition has to be banished
which of course you know goes back
ultimately to the hebrew prophets i mean
that's kind of
a constant idea and um the early
christian missionaries in
in early medieval europe are literally
kind of toppling idols you know they're
chopping down
trees they're sawing them up and turning
them into chapels
and the protestant reformation is is
riffing on the same theme only it's now
taking the roman church as
as um the kind of sump of idolatry that
has to be drained
and the enlightenment is doing exactly
the same but it's now turning its fire
on the whole
edifice of christianity and so it needs
something that it can look back to that
precedes christianity and so it
enshrines
um athenian democracy the roman republic
um greek philosophy as the kind of model
of
an enlightened society that
enlightened people in the 18th century
should probably try and return to
but sard is a kind of sardonic
commentator on that
because you know he lives through the
french revolution i mean he's literally
kevin he's in the bastille a couple of
days before they
they stormed the bastille
and saad recognizes that this is an
illusion
that that there's nothing rational
you know the the the idea that that um
that by kind of overthrowing churches
and
guillotining kings you're somehow going
back
to an enlightened is is is folly
um and it's kind of devastating i mean
that's why he's such a dark figure i
think
yeah kind of terrifying one of the
let's say one of my uh theories in the
past few years that i've been trying to
bring about
is that christianity is a is really a
union of
of opposites it's a union of in the the
christian idea of christ as the union of
god and man there's
this whole idea that he unifies these
extremes in into himself the cross
itself is both
this this image of of a man being
murdered as a criminal but with an
ins with a sign at the top of his head
saying that he's the king
so it's always this union of opposites
and
my theory has been that the modern world
or the modern
movement away from christianity has been
a kind of the incarnation
and we are seeing the opposites pull
apart um
and uh so one of the opposites would be
saad and the will to power rising up and
this kind of this idea of absolute power
that
comes down from above and just imposes
but the other is the the
other let's say parody of that which is
the uh
the the reign of the weak or the weak
that wants
justice for themselves and so the the
communists you know you you can see it
in the opposite of the nazis and the
communists it's an easy way to
understand it where
warranted is absolute order cutting off
anything marginal that doesn't fit
just burning it off and the other is
taking all the marginal stuff and
raising it up to the
the highest ground um and so i don't
know if you've ever thought about it in
those terms
well and i think about it in a slightly
different term because i
i um i i think that
the french revolution and then the
russian revolution
and um the the kind of ripples out from
from marx
are very much going with the grain of
christian tradition
because actually what's radical about um
the crucifixion um isn't the torture
it's the fact that the tortured person
triumphs over the torturer it's it's the
idea that
the slave actually turns out to be the
king
um that you know the first will be last
and the last shall be first
that is what's really paradoxical that's
what's
really novel because there's no great
paradox in the idea that the strongest
role
the paradox lies in the fact that it's
the weak who are strong
and that's what the french revolution
plays with that's what the russian
revolution play with
and even though they famously
notoriously
um reject institutional christianity
they actually do it for very christian
reasons
they see you know the french
revolutionaries see the church
as an overweening powerful
institution that has kept the poor uh
downtrodden
so likewise the the bolsheviks in the
russian revolution
um to a degree now in uh you know the
past summer
um uh people who
um are pushing social justice uh
causes are targeting churches and the
statues of missionaries and so on
because they see them as being hegemonic
as being
kind of i don't know heteronormative and
uh sexist and whatever white supremacist
then yeah it's an embodiment of
of of what is first that has to be
become last
um i think that the nazis
the fascists let's say the fascists more
properly say looking
mussolini before hitler the fascists are
consciously obsessed by
the pre-classical world in a kind of
sardian sense
they worship its its strength its glory
they're not interested in the weak the
downtrodden the poor
uh and they look to the future they look
to a supposedly you know post-christian
world where it will all be
um it'll go away oh yeah it'll be kind
of airplanes and steel
and you know i mean kind of highways and
the trains are run on time and all that
kind of stuff
and it's a fusion of the pre-christian
and the supposedly post-christian
now of course there are christian
elements within
um within fascism hitler and mussolini
were both catholic they were both
very clearly drew on the kind of the
the the mastery of spectacle that the
catholic church embodied
the strain of anti-semitism in um uh
in nazism particularly um
clearly drawing on on the great
inheritance of christian
anti-semitism which has been a kind of
stain right right right from the
beginning
and the apocalyptic strain the the idea
of a thousand year reich
that also is part of the mix but i think
that just reflects the way in which
even the nazis find it impossible
completely to get to get rid of the
christian inheritance because
to a degree that no one has done since
the time of constantine
the nazis do succeed in rejecting not
just institutional christianity
but the entire framework
of values and ethics that christians and
post-christians have upheld of which the
two
major ones are precisely the idea that
the first shall be last and the last
should be first the nazis do not
believe that the nazis do not believe
that weakness is a source of strength
they see weakness as a source of
weakness and therefore to be crushed
and eliminated and the nazis repudiate
the idea which the french
revolutionaries with their
their their their proclamation of
universal values universal rights
and the and this and the communists with
their proclamation of the universal
dictatorship of the proletariat
both uphold the idea that there is a
kind of commonality of human experience
the nazis decisively reject that they
repudiate the poor line idea
that there is no jew or greek absolutely
jews
and greeks are completely different and
that's what provides them with the
license to
to to launch genocide yeah and i think
that there's a a sense in which
um the shock that that delivered to
the west was so profound that now in a
sense
um although we remain deeply christian
we remain christian because we're
horrified
by the nazi distortion of christianity
rather than because we're obedient to
what christianity actually teaches so we
we are
we we get our christian morals and
ethics
from from our revulsion at the at the
nazis who who rejected it
yeah well i think i think that
i agree with most of what you're saying
i think that the only place and i saw
this when i was reading the book
there was a little there were these
little places where i wanted to push
back
on on your thesis a little bit and it
started right away at the beginning when
you mentioned that
saint paul talks about of course this
this passage that you mentioned that
there is no
jew or greek there is no man or woman
but then there are other texts where
saint paul talks about a natural
hierarchy between
man and woman for example and i remember
the way you phrase it was that he
doesn't dare to go to the end of his
own of his own thinking let's say he
doesn't want to push it to the end
and i think that for me that is the
place where i'm not sure
i that i i agree in the sense that if
you if
like i said i see even in the story of
christ for example
there's a reason why christ is shown as
entering jerusalem in
glory before he's crucified right yet
he's hailed his king
and then he's crucified as a criminal
right those two images are there to kind
of act as this
this joining of opposite so the cross is
there
yes as this idea that the last is the
first and the and the weak
can you know that there's a joining of
these opposites but there's also the
moment right before where he's hailed as
as the king and coming into the city and
we see that all through in my
vision when we see that all through
christianity where
for example christianity never does
create at least at the beginning doesn't
create a social revolution
it it the christians martyrs die and
they die and they die and then the
emperor converts
and now then you find this strange
balance and you see how the balance
happen over and over you know the
the the germans and the the northerners
come in they kill they kill they kill
then they convert and then they become
knights and they integrate the hierarchy
where
at least the ideal of the knight is to
use
power and authority to protect the weak
so then you have this balance of this
idea that yes we have
an hierarchy yes we have power yes we
have even empire
but the purpose of empire is to protect
the weak
and so it's not the we it's not the same
as the weak take com
rising up and taking power that i don't
see i don't see neither in the christian
story
nor in the early church or the early
martyrs or
and i see that you frame it like for
example you frame the gregorian uh
reforms that kind of like that uh
wow i don't know go ahead well i i i
mean
clearly christ's crucifixion you know
christ's death on the cross
would be meaningless if he were not
the king yeah i mean otherwise it's it's
nothing and people
say a guy dying you know unless christ
is risen
then then then what we believe is folly
you know it's not
it it it has no hope at all um
so it is fundamental to christ's mission
that he is indeed
god as as as well as as man otherwise
there's
there's nothing there so yes absolutely
um and i
i completely agree that um you know paul
is not interested in preaching
social revolution uh that's not what
he's about and i think that
he's not absolutely certain what he is
about and i i
i and and i mean that you know that
coming from other
other way you know i suppose
particularly jewish and muslim the
immense bodies of law um
[Music]
you know whether it's the talmud or the
sunnah or whatever
um what's what's really striking about
paul
is that his letters are not meant to be
prescriptive like that
they that they are in a sense dramatic
monologues
you know they they they are quite close
to say cicero's speeches
um you know you when you write when he's
writing to the galatians
you you sense what the other guy might
say
you know as you do when you read a
cicero's speech you only get cicero's
okay but but what you also get with paul
is the sense that he's
he's he's thinking aloud so that's in
that sense that it's a kind of dramatic
monologue
and you constantly feel and that's why i
found so powerful about it
he he is wrestling with something
that he cannot put into words he's cut
he's struggling to compute what it means
and my guess is that whether he has a
vision on the road to damascus or not i
mean what you
agreed i don't know whether we can trust
that accountant acts as
as being a historical record but
something like that clearly does happen
he clearly does have
some overwhelming experience in which he
comes to realize that this crucified
criminal is is in some way god
and i can only assume that he comes to
that conclusion
because he has the revelation
and then he he has to think what's going
on here i mean how whoa
and and and then he he he said he's a
highly literate man steeped in
in the scriptures of his people and so
he goes through and he reads the
scriptures
and it's reading the scriptures that
gives him the kind of
sense of of what's gone on he he
interprets the scriptures
retrospectively through his experience
and so he then has to try and formulate
what this means
and the letters seem to me a pr an
attempt
to try and explain that and that's why
they are so incredibly fertile for
future generations
is that in a sense paul himself
isn't entirely clear what it is that
he's trying to say
but because they are kind of marinated
in the incredible richness
of the um the jewish scriptural
tradition
and also of course the fact that paul is
is someone moving around the roman world
this globalized
um world and he has a working knowledge
of
um of of uh he writes in greek
he he knows about stoicism all of this
is a kind of
blends together to create this
incredible
well i mean i kind of think of it as a
depth charge
that goes off underneath fabric of of
the of the roman world
and it it ripples outwards
in ways that perhaps paul would would
find completely shocking
um and so that that thing you know the
the um there's no greek or do no man or
woman knows label free which
which seems so fundamental
to the way that that we in the west now
think
and organize ourselves morally ethically
societally
of course the the key phrases in that is
in christ jesus
you know it's not a manifesto for social
revolution
but but the potential is there
yeah you can see and those ripples go
spilling out and spilling out and
spilling out
or it's an acorn you know it's a tiny
acorn from which this great
oak would grow and part again part of
the power of christianity
is that it lends itself so
prodigiously to metaphor to parable
i mean that's the other great thing is
that is is it's
i hope i don't just focus on paul
because there's also the parables the
power of those parables
to effect change and in a way they are
even more influential
so i the the last chapter you know i
begin with the migration crisis in
europe where you have angela merkel
saying yeah okay come on in and victor
orban saying no don't come in you're a
bunch of muslims we're defending
christian europe let's put up the um
let's put up the barbed wire offense
um merkel merkel is clearly inspired by
the
by the parable with samaritan um you
know the
the whole of this transformative
convulsive episode
that had such an impact on on on europe
is ultimately due to a short story
interesting i one of the questions i
really wanted to pose
for to you and i have two questions left
i guess is
have you thought a little about a little
bit about this idea of this death of
christianity
and this this breakdown or we can see
the influences of christianity kind of
spreading out and
and what i'd see as becoming opposites
have you thought about the i the image
of antichrist
that is given in christianity both in
saint paul and
and you see it in the gospels obviously
in revelation the idea that somehow
the the breakdown of christianity is
part of the story
that christianity itself sets itself up
to die
that it's gonna die and there's
something that's gonna there's
there's a there's a mechanism within the
very pattern
which is is is going to
upend it and going to to to to destroy
it or to
it's going to it's going to scandal is
going to happen as christ said right
scandal needs to happen but woe to those
by whom it happens
and so i was wondering if you had
thought a little bit about that pattern
in your in in your thinking
well okay so two responses to that
one is the the the story of antichrist
which then of course bleeds into
revelation so antichrist first appears
in uh in paul's letters
um but then it bleeds into revelation
and um becomes a kind of entire
mythology of the future
which um it is incredible
and continues to be incredibly powerful
but it's something that i think that
certainly in um
in the west uh christians have become
embarrassed about
um and the whole kind of supernatural
superstructure
of angels and devils and heaven and hell
um has become a kind of thing of mockery
so so the um the
the viral video of trump's spiritual
advisor summoning angels from africa i
mean people just found it
you know hilarious and i think that
that's a problem for institutional
christianity
if if all this stuff is seen as being
you know essentially risible and even
you know i don't know what you know
bishops here in england
i mean they they rather steal from a
poor box and talk about angels i think
or devils i mean it's all you know but i
think that that is you know that that
that is a crucial part of it
and i think that that's one of the
reasons why the church is growing so
explosively in africa
is that perhaps um you know that
dimension of spirits of of angels and
and devils
it seems much closer or why
pentecostalism
is by miles the fastest growing
expression of christianity
globally is because there people do take
spirits they do take it
you know seriously and they kind of open
themselves up to it so um
i think that in a way
that you know the antichrist um the
devil
you know it's such a crucial part of the
christian story but in a way it's
it's the part of it that's hardest for
me
to get to to get to get back at i can
kind of look at it as
you know rather you know to to in a way
it's it's a it's a source of great
frustration to me because
the power of it is so incredible and you
just have to go through christian
history
and realize how i mean it just kind of
changes i mean kind of everything
ever all is endlessly coming back yeah
and endlessly compulsive you know the
great thing in in the reformation is is
is it it's one of the things that joins
you know it's the
truly ecumenical thing is both sides
sinking the other around christ yeah
yeah yeah yeah
but i think that there are keys to rega
recapturing that i guess i would say
part of my work what a large part of my
work is help people
recapture it in a way that is that fits
within even modern categories
uh and it's really i think that going
back and also understanding
some kind of what you see in the church
father is if you look at the righteous
father say maximus or
gregor of nisa the more intellectual
fathers you could say
you find keys in there to help you deal
with the problem
of angels um and it has to do with the
notion of intelligences
and and pattern and the idea that there
are pattern beings
above us we know there are because
cities are patterned beings
above us they they have a pattern and
they're we can recognize them as
as existing we can say london exists
even though it's a million
of details and you can still see that it
exists and so it has an intelligence it
has something
like i can write to london and london
will answer me right i can write to my
city
and it'll answer me i i can complain to
the city and the city will answer me and
the person
who's writing the letter is not is not
the person answering me really
they're just a tool of the of the city
and so we get
as we start as we as we're if we're able
to perceive that
there are there are patterns which exist
above
just material reality and those patterns
stack up
from a person to a family to a community
to a
to a city et cetera et cetera then the
idea that
let's say the angel of new york
uh can fall and then that's it
new york's gonna go down right if if
it's spirit falls then it's
then it's over but we we are able to
recognize this spirit right because i
can recognize a new yorker even if i'm
in canada
i can recognize uh someone from chicago
i know i
there are ways to recognize people who
belong to corporate bodies that are
higher than than the that's a uh
an individual and those those become
ways to
recapture and especially with the new
science of consciousness like
the these new ideas that the
inevitability of consciousness to
for reality to appear to us right the
categories are go through our
intelligence it's harder and harder to
to uh to
ignore that then we can then notice
these corporate beings of course
we can't we can't do it like you said
you know it exactly yet
in the same way that ancient people can
because
we're we're so materialist that it's
hard for us to encounter it but we get
there's a subtle
capacity to encounter corporate beings
uh
like i said uh you can you can still you
can write to santa claus and santa claus
will answer you you can write to all
kinds of corporate beings and they they
answer
but i i one of the um one of the
chapters that i ended up not writing
um basically because i know you're
orthodox aren't you
yeah so so i i decided i couldn't i i
wasn't going to go into orthodox
christianity because it was just too
huge topic yeah but if i had done all if
i had
done orthodox christianity as well then
i would have linked dostoevsky
and nature and um
the the the obvious parable in in
dostoevsky is the
parable of the grand inquisitor in
brothers for amazon
um and i think that what that touches on
is dostoevsky sense that there is
perhaps something within
um latin christianity
that has kind of inevitably moved
towards atheism
that there's there's a progress within
um
everything that that that has made latin
christianity
so dynamic and and so incapable of of
staying still
um that has ultimately kind of
inevitably
led to it to atheism has inevitably led
to
um you know christ returns and
the grand inquisitor locks him up um you
know
angels are irradiated devils are
banished um
we we get rid of everything and we end
up with auschwitz
that that europe's experience of of
modernity
um
is is in a way shadowed by by western
christendom's
suicide the the the
there are dimensions and you know and
it's not just western you know it's
there's something within christianity
that leads to its own
inevitable termination
i think it does well i think there's a
resurrection but i do think that it
leads
i think there's something there's a cr
christ set up a pattern that was going
to lead to
uh personal death and then uh corp
corporate death and it was just par it's
a frag it's a fractal pattern that is
repeating itself and so i to me i'm not
i don't like it but i'm not surprised
that it's happening because
it's there in christ's story it's there
in christ's story
and he's rejected by his own people like
christ is it's judas who betrays him
it's from within his disciples that he
was going to he was going to be betrayed
it's
atheism had to rise out of christianity
there was no
other place where it could come from
because
it's that that's the pattern of the
story
and you know desacralization is often
you know it has long been applied to
protestantism
um and and i think that's that that's
true i think that that
protestantism does consciously kind of
aims
to de-sacralize an enormous amount that
that catholicism had represented
but the whole christianity is a process
of desacralization
um you know i think of um
milton's great poem on the nativity
which essentially consists of all the
gods
going oh milton describes the greek gods
egyptian gods the canaanite gods
basically all being banished um you know
for milton the gods are real
but they're demons what then happens is
that christians come to think that they
never existed
yeah you know these ancient gods never
existed
um and then that's kind of intermediate
stage and then from that it's not that
much further to go on saying well
actually christian god never existed
so there's a sense in which christians
are sitting on a branch and sawing that
branch off
yeah and and all those all those all
those all those gods are waiting to
to to eat us up like the mouth of hell
at the bottom
once the branch gets cut off we'll see
it's it's it's hard to know what's going
to happen but
that we can feel the let's say we can
see
all these all the principalities now
fighting
to know which one is going to rule you
see but you see i think
i think that um there is
i i think that people cannot survive
without
let's call it myth in the non-pejorative
sense
sense that there is a kind of potent
story that
explains things more deeply and
profoundly than than
the shell of reality does and
in a way all the kind of you know the
movie franchises
harry potter and avengers and lord of
the rings and
all that kind of stuff it's kind of
an ersatz attempt to fill in the gap
it's um it's expressive
of people's ache for for the kind of
story
that the churches used to tell yeah i
don't think that the churches have the
confidence to tell that story anymore
i think that that and so i think that
the the kind of
the cultural the moral the spiritual
brew that the churches serve up
is is very anemic um it it's not
satisfying in the way that that story
used to be
i think the same is also true of of
secular humanism
i think it's true of um you know of
social justice movements i think it's
incredibly telling that social justice
movements
kind of almost despite themselves reach
after the kind of
gestures and displays and narratives
that clearly demonstrate that they are
deriving from christianity
they're washing people's feet toppling
statues
um proclaiming that um you know
slaves have been brought into a promised
land all these stories
but because they've been divorced from
the kind of
fabric of um of uh
from which these stories originally
emerged you know they've been divorced
from the matrix of that
they seem to me kind of
well a bit dull to be honest yeah kind
of dull and hectoring
and unable for instance to kind of
um hook into the the mainframe of
people's emotional
and and spiritual responses in the way
that social the
the civil rights movement could because
martin luther king
you know he could he could invoke the
crucifixion he could invoke the story of
exodus
he could echo the language of the
cadences of the bible
and do it in a way that didn't feel as
acts
now he was summoning the immense heft of
this incredible
story and
i think that that's that that that's why
the civil rights movement
had the impact that it did why it came
to be almost
so universally accepted and why
today's kind of um social justice
movements
are far far more divisive because they
they cannot tap into you know
not only do they can they not tap into
these stories but they kind of set
themselves against it
the echoes that they they have within
themselves of these stories
are something that that objectively
they're guarding against
you know the id is is absolutely part of
it but the ego is standing
full square against it and i think that
that makes their appeal incredibly
limited
and so i think that um you know
my prescription for
for christianity to make a kind of
you know come back in terms of people
going to church and sitting in pews
would be for christian leaders to
embrace everything that they spent the
past century rejecting
the kind of i you know christianity in
the west seems to me a palette similar
yeah
it used to be yeah well it's i think
that it's
at least in the one of the reasons why i
became orthodox was also because i could
see you know i'm i'm mostly an artist
and
i noticed and i learned about the the
pattern of storytelling and the
pattern of image making it's a it's
really like almost like a sacred algebra
and
it's a self-contained language that
moves between imagery
and architecture and music and all of
this and so in discovering that i
realized that
it's i believe i believe that if we
rediscover the stories
and the legends especially if we if we
stop being sola scripture all the
legends and we
let's say we at least understand their
function we can understand the function
of the legends and the function of the
wilder aspects of our tradition
then there are ways back in they're
they're harder but there are ways back
in using
uh phenomenological approaches to
existence you know i tell people yes
the you know the sun the earth turns
around the sun but the sun still gets up
in the morning you can't avoid that and
the sun
still goes down in the evening and you
can't avoid it and your day is still
managed
by that pattern so that pattern is real
and and the fact that our days and the
the liturgical cycle
follows the natural patterns uh those
can still be real
when you watch uh you know when you
watch the leaves fall those are real
patterns of death and rebirth that
you're experiencing so when christ is
born in the cave on nativity
and it's the lowest day of the year and
it's the solstice
this is a real experience you can have
of the of the shortest day
and the seed planted in darkness which
will rise again
because the because it actually follows
a natural pattern of of nature
you can't yeah you can't completely get
rid of it
i i entirely understand the tug of of
orthodoxy i mean i i i really do
but but equally what i found when i was
writing dominion and i was kind of
um you know it was kind of it was like a
constant
process of kind of rushing into another
sweetie shop and gorging myself on
suites and then
not having to you know i had to kind of
rush off and go to another one i mean i
could happily have spent
you know years in any of the periods
that i write about
but i found um
that it was
again and again there were certain um
points where what i was writing about
was personal for me
and i i so pilgrim's progress for
instance
actually seems to me you know this was
this was the most read book after the
bible
in england for for centuries um after
bunyan wrote it
and i remember reading it as a child and
returning to it uh it
it just i just kind of allude to it in a
single sentence not by name in dominion
but it was kind of quite important
in in opening my eyes to you know
reminding me of the power of the
protestant story
um you know that kind of dissenting
non-conformist
um understanding and that's done through
through a story and that story seemed
you know incredibly vivid to me this
this time under lockdown um
i i had my eyes open to the way that the
canterbury tales chaucer's canterbury
tales
is is full of a kind of
christian magic in a way that i'd never
understood eating it before
because the opening of the canterbury
tales i i would i had been planning to
to walk with my brother through kent so
in april um you know country tales
famously opens with
with april and the pilgrims meeting in a
pub in in south london
reading in lockdown um unable to go
and meet pilgrims you know unable to go
and do this walk with my brother
made me think god how amazing it would
be to go to a pub until not socially
distanced with people
meet up with total strangers and get out
of london and go and walk
to canterbury and chaucer specifies that
people going to canterbury
to talk to the tomb of thomas beckett
because he makes people who are sick
well i suddenly thought of course plague
was endemic in london
when chaucer was writing this and it's
worse over the winter
so the whole thing about going on
pilgrimage in
april is you can you can escape the play
you can escape the death
and you can go to the shrine and you can
give thanks for
you know the fact that you're alive that
you're you're out there that you're with
other people
um and suddenly i had a sense of how
powerful it must be
to go on pilgrimage to a shrine like the
one that that
was in canterbury until the reformation
and you know
and and i felt like you know this was
you know this was part of my past part
of my cultural reading part of my
cultural inheritance
suddenly being given fresh life by the
experience of the pandemic
so kind of sense of light coming out of
the darkness
and those kind of experiences as
is what the the the the process of of
thinking about christianity in the way
that i have done for
what the past five years has given me
it's it's kind of made me alert
personally i mean i just for me
to the incredible wealth
of of the different ways of seeing the
world kind of like taking a drug that it
kind of
changes the way you see color changes
the way that you you experience reality
and that's what christianity you know
gives it had this
incredible inheritance of literature of
of
um art of music of uh
sensory experience um you know of travel
all this kind of stuff and i i feel
so grateful that i've gone through it
and that i know that it will
continue to give me these incredible
experiences these incredible insights
and and what a you know what a resource
that is
but i do think that that um
you know the questions about well
what what is is that enough for
for people or is it do you need more and
of course that's a question that i i do
wrestle with quite a lot what about
what about i don't know like i i don't
know your your
let's say your situation right now i
mean what
has it for you has it been enough to
kind of bring you
actually into church like would it would
it be enough to bring you into church
yeah so i i when i was um writing the
book i went to a number of churches
um you know if i was writing about the
reformation i go to a lutheran church
and
so on um and
i there's a wonderful church in london
um which was founded in the reign of
henry the first
but supposedly by his jester who got ill
and went
to rome and uh perfect church for right
now yeah absolutely i had
a vision of um saint bartholomew
who told him to go back and found a
hospital in a priory so he did that
and so the church is a part of what was
the priory
and the hospital saint bartholomew's is
still a functioning hospital in the
middle of london
so that's a norman church where the
virgin appeared
um it's the only appearance of the
virgin in london and she turned up and
kind of
bollocked a load of monks he was saying
the literally wrong and then vanished um
and then chunks of it got closed down in
the reformation sold off and what had
been the lady chapel became
a printer's where benjamin franklin
worked for a year so
the whole church seemed to me perfect
embodiment of everything that dominion
is about so i
i fell very much in love with it it's
kind of beautifully done
um but also i had this amazing
experience in um
in the church in the village where i i
grew up where my mother still goes to
church
um which is very much the kind of
protestant experience of
um a great preacher suddenly catching
fire and
pentecostal flame coming down and it was
this this um
uh woman who who you know it was
incredibly drab service i thought it was
going to be it was kind of about eight
eight eight of us huddled in in quiet
stools
very early in the morning um and she
just gave this amazing service
where she talked about the dove um at
the baptism coming down and how
the dove was a sacrificial animal in the
temple
so um christ was baptized with blood as
well as with water and how this was a
form of you know
pregnancy you know giving birth and it
was so
literate and it was so scholarly and it
was so emotional and it was so
beautiful and i just kind of went wow
that's that's incredible
um so i did i i i i have had you know
it's i haven't just studied christianity
as though it's a kind of butterfly
pinned on a board i have
kind of experienced the the slipstream
of it the top of it
very very powerfully well that's oh
that's wonderful i
all i can say is i i looking forward to
seeing where you
will you end up on this path let's say
and where you're going in these
reflections
and so i want to encourage everybody to
to get dominion everybody watches it's
definitely
worth it it's very refreshing uh like i
said the chapters
especially the chapters as we move
towards modernity there really is this
momentum that gets built up and you
start to see
let's say the the consequence of his
thesis
of tom's thesis which is you know how
this is going to influence even as
christianity's being
is being eroded we see the influence
continue and so it becomes very magical
as the book continues and so tom thank
you thank you for your time and i really
enjoyed our discussion
thanks very much for having me all right
it's good to talk to you